Jetzt müsst ihr starke nerven haben gleich seht ihr die ersten bilder von aliens die sich auf
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse stützen und ich muss sagen schön sind sie nicht allein zumindest
gewöhnungsbedürftig ein forschungsteam aus oxford hat einen komplett neuen ansatz genutzt
Um endlich herauszufinden wie unsere außerirdischen nachbarn aussehen könnten und ihr ergebnis
Ist verblüffend wie das forschungsteam auf dieses ergebnis gekommen ist um wie konkret wir uns also unsere?
Außerirdischen nachbarn vorstellen müssen jetzt sind klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja heute aus duisburg das ist sie gibt das ist bei den meisten wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftlern umstritten doch
Wo genau sie stecken und wie sie aussehen die
außerirdischen das wissen wir nicht seit vielen jahrzehnten suchen forschungsteams weltweit nach, ihnen wir analysieren
Planetensysteme horchen ins alle und untersuchen monde
Indizien für ihre existenz gibt es noch
Und nöcher es fehlt nur noch der eindeutige beweis und so stellt auch das forschungsteam aus oxford gleich am anfang der wissenschaftlichen abhandlung
namens darwins aliens erst einmal klar etwas über das aussehen oder das verhalten von aliens zu erforschen das sei
Wahrhaftig nicht einfach doch dann geht es auch schon ans eingemachte
Konkret geht es an die
Evolutionstheorie charles darwin viele von euch haben ein bisschen davon ja in der schule mit bekommt doch dass sie auch genutzt werden kann um medien
vorhersagen zu machen
Darauf ist bisher noch niemand gekommen bislang die man
Eher von modellen aus die man hier auf der erde in fachbereichen wie biologie
Physik und chemie beobachten kann um das dann zu übertragen und so rückschlüsse auf das aussehen und das verhalten von aliens zu bekommen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler von der universität oxford gehen jetzt tatsächlich zum ersten mal von der
Evolutionstheorie des guten alten charles darwins aus ihre these genau wie das leben auf unserer erde sind auch außerirdische der natürlichen selektion
Ausgesetzt heißt also konkret nur die lebewesen die am stärksten und fittesten sind überleben so müssen sich also auf fremde lebensformen auf fremden planeten
Immer wieder weiterentwickeln um zu überleben weiter gehen die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler davon aus dass auch in der heimat von
außerirdischen große veränderungen stattgefunden haben bzw stattfinden die dann wiederum große
evolutionäre schritte zur folge haben ebenso wie bei der entwicklung des lebens auf der erde
Mit großen veränderungen sind solche entwicklung gemeint die immer komplexere und höhere lebensformen
Hervorbringen beispielsweise die entwicklung zu einem mehrzelligen organismus nur die die am besten an ihre umwelt
Angepasst sind überleben und das könnte zb so aussehen ein riesiger wurm der otto mied er
Existiert unter der planetenoberfläche und besteht aus verschiedenen wesen die voneinander abhängig sind und miteinander
Parieren wie sehe da eine erste begegnung aus oder solche wesen am ende so das fazit
Des forschungsteams könnte ein außerirdisches wesen entstanden sein dass uns menschen sehr ähnlich ist sam levin einer der beteiligten forscher
Formuliert das so vorausgesetzt dass aliens großen veränderungen ausgesetzt sind was dem entsprechen würde wie sich
Komplexität in den arten auf der erde aus gebildet hat können wir sagen
Dass eine gewisse berechenbarkeit der evolution dazu führen würde dass sie aussehen wie wir und das forschungsteam ist von seinem ergebnis
Überzeugt ihre theoretischen voraussagen zum menschen den alien gelten auch für diejenigen unter den aliens die beispielsweise
stickstoff atmen oder keine dna besitzen das alles klingt ganz logisch denn warum sollten lebensformen
Im all nicht ähnliche lösungen für ihre probleme gefunden haben wie wir natürlich jeweils
Angepasst an ihre umweltbedingungen in einer umwelt mit viel licht wäre es ja durchaus sinnvoll so etwas wie ein auge
Zu entwickeln um es jedoch zwei oder sechs sind so konkret werden die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler aus oxford nicht
das sagen sie auch selbst so sam levin
wir können immer noch nicht sagen ob williams auf zwei beinen laufen oder große grüne augen haben werden andere
astrobiologen sehen das etwas anders
Manche von ihnen sind überzeugt davon dass die meisten der extraterrestrischen
Lebewesen ihre existenz schon längst geupdatet haben auf eine künstliche intelligenz die uns weit überlegen ist das ist eine extrem spannende
Abnahme dazu sollte ich mal ein video machen und wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier an abo
Aufs auge und vergessen nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter wenn ihr drauf klickt mit haben die aliens zu uns gelockt
vielleicht sind sie also schon da ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran